listen carefully
we have lost objective anthem
you
good morning everyone in the US and good
day or good evening to everyone else
around the world
I'm Michael hi I'm joined by my good
friend Rob handler II it's so great to
be here yes and we have battlefield 5
gameplay for y'all we have access to the
the closed alpha closed alpha and it
started at 1:00 a.m. our time which rob
was here since 1 a.m. been playing oh
that would have been insane although it
was tempting I showed up at what time do
I wake up at 4:00 stared at a wall for
about an hour and then I came in yeah
and I clocked out I always wake up
caught Rob here of course he was flying
planes but as we know battlefield 5 is
coming out later this year but we have
access to the closed alpha I saw him
flying planes and all that stuff but
we're gonna get into get into a little
bit of the action here for everyone
because I know that not everyone has
access to the closed alpha but we do so
we're gonna play the game for hours on
end for everyone watching out there
probably like 2 hours all right
I'm thinking maybe okay so the cool
thing here what I realized I mean you
know again this is close alpha so it's
not the full game so you're not able to
you know customize your companies which
is kind of a big deal
armory there's only one assignment here
capture 10 objectives I've been doing a
little bit got a got one headshot as a
sniper
okay so we got a little taste of
everything or a little taste of
something a little taste of the
assignments you know measure like
challenges in the last game I think they
were called assignments as well actually
in battlefield one but the the one thing
I would say is that well most people
have only seen I think is just a as far
as from e3 is just grand operations
right now we have the classic conquest
so I've been playing that and that's
what we should dabble in okay wait times
haven't been too bad okay yeah you were
in current quick match just now or okay
we're finding a gamer myself finding
yeah alright so we're gonna try and find
a simple conquest match for everyone mmm
there absolutely and we'll see what we
can do and there's a one map for grant
operations and one map for conquest
right now it's the same map I believe
okay I'm gonna butcher the name Narvik
I'm gonna get to this is the one that
takes place in probably got it better
than I can
Oh what is it
Norway yeah that's about right yeah I
think that yeah it's gonna be that
that's snow
that's know a map they were showing off
and at e3 mm-hmm
so we got you didn't get a chance to
play it at e3 so this is uh this is a
big deal to you yeah I love battlefield
games so much especially a huge fan of
1942 so whoo yes to go back to the roots
it's very sweet right so yeah you know
it's it's it's here we go
awesome yeah the one thing I was telling
you before we started was like the most
notable change from battlefield one is
the movement it's it's tight it you you
feel very mobile
yeah and capable of like just quick
reaction shots like I don't know like
everything about it it feels a lot more
fluid I would say yeah just the
sprinting and like the popping out of
cover and stuff like it's noticeably
different okay
yeah I've been enjoying that yeah and I
mentioned this to you earlier is that I
felt like battlefield 1 was a pretty
vast improvement in terms of improvement
of movement in terms of like being able
to jump cover and go prone and feeling
like you're not stuck anywhere yes I
think that was one of the things in the
battlefield series that it wasn't too
great on like individual mobility
because it was more about like vehicles
and tanks and all the other stuff yeah
it speaking of vehicles I gots to get me
into one of these Stukas laws I've taken
Rob's bribes really into his plane I
will I don't I won't spend too much time
in playing so good ok at 6:30 in the
morning first thing I see his Rob flying
planes and dropping bombs yeah so the
Germans have the Stuka dive-bomber which
is that has that classic Jericho noise
this is like that which is like cool
anyways that's not happening because all
the people are gone so this is still the
same setup as far as a little wonder how
you get into vehicles you kind of spawn
into them which is kind of bummer
because I prefer to take off on a runway
but hey
oh well cool all right so we're into the
action here for battlefield 5
battlefield B which whichever way you
want to call it v-day yes V for victory
so one thing I haven't was know us to do
is you like will Auto pick up health and
ammo which is a big a big change into
this game now is like the scarcity of
ammo and stuff right so oh yeah well I'm
running out any only have yeah you'll
have one one extra clip yeah one extra
clip I'm really into that me too it's
it's tight it's like it's it's fun to
have that that desperation and you know
you're picking up any weapons you're
you're changing up habits yeah let's get
into it get snowy it's got some capture
points here again where we're playing
the Conquest mode the classic
battlefield Conquest mode here because
the closed alpha includes that first go
get them
okay this will be plenty live alone hit
him a little bit at least he'll I'm
gonna try and stay quiet for wrong
you're good you're good
alright never mind if you guys are any
questions in the chat like yes
definitely throw them in there Michael
will draw to answer them or I can help
try to pull them up I don't have that
that little hand oh no we do nevermind
hey there on that handy-dandy
application that they use is to pull up
all chats but let's suppose we do I'm
like already like running on ammo here
man
yeah you don't even have a full clip
right now no I like that I like not not
feeling like I'm a super soldier or if
like you know I want to feel scrap these
situations
yeah I always find in these games I die
before I get to actually use my
secondary weapon so yeah right you
actually have to utilize and think about
let's see what am I gonna use my
secondary right so just there I picked
up some ammo okay
it felt like it and it was only like 18
bullets it wasn't like oh I got like 90
bullets right and so the same the same
thing goes for oh there you go now you
now you stock done okay same thing goes
for planes too so like it's it's crazy
like planes normally had like only like
nine hundreds of bullets
stars like their primary machine gun so
like that's it's crazy to see that
number not like an infinite sign he no
enemy so there's like a an icon in sky
for planes to like fly through and rearm
alright so can we see battery out no
there is no battle royale mode in this
right now they have you who knows it I
don't think it's gonna be at launch
isn't that what they said that they're
working at or that confirmed I'm
actually not sure I think the word on
the street was that it wasn't gonna be
out there at launch because they're
working on it but I know at EA play they
said straight up alright we'll go about
we're gonna have better way out but or
right out right something like there you
got battle yeah battlefield bro out
we'll see where that goes but for now we
have we have grant operations we have
conquests and we're playing conquest
right now classic yes a little bit of
flanking here Oh
what's the minimum required specs for
this game oh man that's something I
should know
being very interested in PC hardware and
all that I actually I should have looked
that up that's a good question kind of
dead got me Rob
so the revive is big too right like oh
and there it is again so I'm just down
oh okay
you've done son now I'm done so now
what's cool as I can see my squad and
decide whether I spawn on him if I might
spawn this guy now
what regular using I think we haven't
yet I 760 700 K in this computer and a I
think this is 1070 GTX 1070 okay and
we're running this at 1080p we're now
running this 4k or 1440p or all that
yeah and figure what the settings at all
I did I looked around they don't have
any options to change like textures like
its generic like I can't like booster to
ultra settings were what we're not okay
but as far as the other control like it
seems to be fairly we in-depth as far as
like close to release I would say as far
as customized customizable like options
right like there's a lot going on hi
whoa oh oh snap
oh I fly alright
don't let your boys I'm sorry it but
yeah Battlefield games are known for
their heavy customization when it comes
to graphics options so I would I would
expect more of the same here I don't see
what else any changes in the closed
alpha besides Tim your homescreen
Conquest mode what we're playing right
now let's see what else what other
questions I may be wrong but I'm pretty
sure that's the biggest change for the
closed alpha yeah like I think they were
just showing off the Korean operation
okay cool let's see what else is this
better I'll note is the new Club gene
map closed but nope
do you know if this game has attachments
like battlefield one more like
battlefield 4 or anything like that it
will have attachments that is I can show
you what custom I mean I can only choose
ok your weapons yeah so they have held
off all the customisation type stuff and
they've mentioned that like here you can
work ok yeah this is what the PPE SH was
called that didn't have a red dot scope
on it
I don't believe back in the day but yeah
I take liberties and would have fun
right yes ok ok cool keep the questions
coming and maybe you will try me will
talk to you yeah it's closed beta just
for peace and right now yes I think so
yeah that's the only codes we have about
ours what we were given sure all right
cool semitic
with a sniper gasps did I pick a medic
yeah cool cool yeah you got a syringe it
shoot up so that's the cool change to
right is everyone can revive everyone
yeah need medics can do it faster oh no
that's not you that's your boy oh come
on you got a sniper rifle man could have
pop shots at him no it's okay I was look
let's not be hard on us it's a lot of
pressure to play video games live on
streams all right this guy better come
freakin reviving I haven't been revived
yet anyone can do it no one cares he's
out he's out for himself man conquest is
all about tickets man you gotta save her
tickets this is Trail revive your revive
your friends some pretty snow particles
yeah I would agree like the snow on my
face here we go oh god I hate this the
spawning is like I haven't selected an
awful one if I if I get to like select
it I'm able to like just like time to
customize a game oh here we go Oh let's
go all right Rob happy wait no he's not
Oh like rip my controller and Rob Rob
needs his planes man is all I said a pop
shots
there you go you gotta earn your time on
planes by being a good foot soldier I do
like how you pick up ammo automatically
that's yeah you don't like stare at the
ground and press EEE
right hot spot Oh get him get him
nightstand this guns legit that's pretty
good is that the Gewehr 43 man the fact
that you just said that makes makes me
excited it is world war two guns yeah
sure it is hi
I might do one I'm a medic dude hey deej
oh oh shoot up boy get it don't mess
around
oh nice
things are going well Michael it seems
you guys got the over a hundred ticket
manage know that oh nice y'all go be
fighting over revives no always my it's
a good problem to have I guess I go for
this guy I'm gonna go for me go get him
hopefully I can revive you nice word oh
no another guy nice too far I can't get
this guy though uh-oh are we using a
controller know we got keyboard and
mouse but once we do once we do get a
our hands on a plane Rob will switch
over to an Xbox controller because that
makes sense
it totally does it's it's I think it's
downright yeah I remember yeah I'm uh
I'm a battlefield 1942 guy myself yeah
that was actually a V game that got me
into PC gaming cuz that would be too
yeah yeah cuz I remember watching g4 TV
and they were like yeah battlefield 1942
look how dope this game is like what I
can't get down consoles so I was like
nah I'm sure it was the game that got me
the only time into a clan oh yeah but
and it also was probably the game where
my parents were like alright chill out
like yeah 90 42 was addicting it was
just such a different experience from
what I expected from the games I've
played in the past because I was only
like I was about 13 years old when I
started playing PC games and I was like
wow blown away by the sense of scale of
that
does that have anything like that on
console yeah dude it was something else
yeah I I really wish they feel like over
the years they've they've kind of
abandoned planes in a way this will
Robby's also they have though got my
weight my bucko with hey when you when
you playing like that man you don't no
need for planes I guess psychos no I
mean it's fine like this is this is the
day oh hi together they should gosh so
good man I'm not normally good I don't
know what's going on life like these
guys just suck you've been here since 1
a.m. that's why
come on yeah I'm stalking myself yeah
how this oh dude roll up on you I'm
telling you about everybody's like hi
what are you doing hey where are the bad
guys
okay let's see what else is everyone
talking about in the chat over here
again we're playing the battlefield 5
closed alpha because we got access and
we thought it would be entertaining to
show everyone battlefield 5 in action
amen yeah would have loved a battlefield
2142
yes they're all maka Kevin real cool I
was showering this morning I was
thinking about my battlefield history
man cover me oh yeah that's that good
stuff right there
man if I got shot in the head twice and
someone
juiced me up with whatever that was I'll
be ready to go let's be honest I'm a
damn good medic get your ass up bullets
popping right out of my live in so I'm
ready to go all these guys oh no don't
you go down oh no oh
we'll try noscope oh poor I'll hit
firing with the compare 43
all right Rida but revive overdose yes
man that's that's how that's how a word
dude
can suck dude hey man I mean let's see
if we got any plans no okay yeah yeah
yeah 19 battlefield 1942 I didn't pick
the Stuka oh we ate we got planing take
what you can get robbed
look
Rob cat but to drop bombs on y'all let's
see what you can do Oh get that I don't
have any bombs I can okay sound effects
light sound effects are so good there's
a Messerschmitt Bf 109
okay tell me more it's a great way okay
best fighters in it and that gentlemen
Luftwaffe okay I'm now I'm not too uh
not too knowledgeable when it comes to
aircraft oh man whoa this is fun right
for everyone watching out there if y'all
are dude
this is I can do this all day it doesn't
look very entertaining but ah crap oh no
baby wait my wings do barrel roll man
oh damn all right back to keyboard/mouse
oh yeah you get you going down
oh damn that's Savage oh dude yeah like
the KITT like when you die or get like
in the sky it's like a horrifying scream
and then it cuts out it's like every
time it's like good lord
all right well now we know not to get
outside of the combat zone yeah there
you go spawned on your squad mates
lessons learned back into the action
right there see popping shots now nice
Robert revived that machine gun oh god
oh god whoa it's chill out that's it
whoa hello hello hope he's all right
yeah he's fine robotic enemies have been
closing the gap a little bit here in
this match you guys were up about a
hundred thirty tickets but now you're
only up about 72 yes any tickets got to
keep it up there's still a long match to
go not even halfway there again if
you're not familiar with bow field these
conquest matches you can go on for a
pretty long time so you got to be in it
for the long haul and again we're
playing classical Conquest mode classic
conquests do have grand operations which
a vegetable get into later but now did
I'm the best medic ever hey I don't I
don't doubt it
yeah I really like playing medic in the
battlefield games because at least I
felt somewhat useful yeah see you know
you get shot up it's all good I revived
like five other homies so yeah it's all
good
[Applause]
yeah oh cool
see they got your back too oh there's a
sniper
these are spotting people in this game
grace okay so I believe it's it's far
more difficult like I think you have to
Dan I think you have to be like and have
I like a decent distance in order to do
it and it takes longer for like the
spotting to show up on yeah whatever
yeah like I can can't speak for Val
field one but like battlefield 4 3 like
he'd be in a plane and just go yeah just
uh qqqq yeah I just be mashing Q and
like all right I spotted everyone right
like I don't think that's possible
ok cool alright I really want to get in
a plane again so we're gonna we're gonna
stare at this uh this map screen real
quick before as we wait for a Stuka to
spawn that Rob can get into is that what
you're waiting for you want to Snuka I
mean I'd like one okay how many planes
are in the sky one guy there's normally
two planes at once I could probably
weigh it out narvik is the map normally
yes I don't know sometimes the V might
be a W sounding thing in a week some
kind of European language stripping
sniper if I don't get this Rob is
fiercely clicking the plane respawn so
we'll see how that pans out hey y'all
y'all is losing right now F I said I
said earlier that we were we was up from
130 tickets now we're down about 10
tickets telling me I shouldn't snipe no
you were doing you were doing quite well
for yourself did you shoot a flare hey
sometimes it can burn who knows that'll
work but yeah you know someone come get
me and get my dumb ass me that syringe
Brit
I do like this right revived system is
kind of tight it's just like it's really
short that window yeah and these dudes
real caught really caught up okay oh
there it is now we're oh now we're gonna
win
oh snap drops guys playing watch the
watch the ticket count completely sway
now yeah it's not gonna go anywhere
get
[Music]
great where's Rob Rob's an ace he's an
ace attorney it's boring to watch this I
can't I wouldn't say that I can only
speak for myself is that I was never a
good pilot in any of the battlefield
games so when someone is a decent pilot
I can really appreciate that a good
flight gameplay in battle ooh damn so I
got an tight freaking
oh yeah stalling when you're rushing for
food there's no time for stalling oh my
god
nice undertow I'm sure you have it all
here you drop that drop it to the flow
good choice fun to do this that's pretty
cool
Oh like this guy behind me oh snap do
you stop flying when you do that oh yeah
okay because that supposed to be someone
else oh oh no not a foot kind of fringe
twist it twist it
oh there you go get him yeah
flight game play is extremely hard y'all
should know look at that I'm out I gotta
reload okay really gotta pick your shot
just tough for aerial gameplay yeah
dogfights oh that's why that's cool is
like if you like the anna lilla on my
right wing if it goes out like my
pronounce and i have a hard time turning
oh okay i see so there's a there's a
damage model for the planes themselves
and it affects how the control
yeah and that's pretty interested in i
have like a gadget on the plane
there oh it's got a cool-down I believe
or cancel my wings back it's in the
bottom right yeah so that so I can only
use it so many times got my wings under
me
that's tight all right this guy's take
them out man I can't now come I'm just
gonna roll I gotta get it back Oh way
more damage oh we're back on we're back
on the flow take the subject all right
okay well yeah but we have a tight match
right here it's uh three hundred to
three hundred about when it comes to
tickets whoa behind enemy lines right
here ed oh good stuff Rob this mp40 is
kind of cool nice skin on it oh yeah we
got some gun skins now showing off so
good Rob it was uh oh you got ranked up
to corporal oh my god get him oh I got
it
you got a deep eat there yo you all by
yourself you jump behind enemy lines all
by yourself out that's stupid stupid
right
ask for it that was astute guy all right
working on my plane knowledge let's
we'll swap to like medic like that guru
okay look guys now you're back now
you're back in the trenches with your
friends
show us a little bit of that magic that
you had a had earlier let's get it all
right there you go you got it
great work Rob a lot of people playing
right oh yeah the best it's a pretty
open closed alpha I would say well I
mean if you're gonna have a battlefield
match you gonna want 64 players in there
seems to be running quite well though
all things considered yeah yeah for the
most part like I the only things I can I
find noticeable or drastically noise
more like the vehicles are stuttering or
stuttering yeah like there's some
latency there I felt like all right not
for me just for like you know what do
you know the water at the model let's
see all right if if you all are just
joining us we're playing the battlefield
5 closed alpha here cuz we got some
access and now we want to show y'all the
game is like in action you got robbed on
the patrols over here he's been doing
quite well one of the show they're the
KD ratio or if you want to show that Oh
18 9 okay spend my time that damn plane
don't blame yourself don't be shooting
dead bodies man yeah fix yourself up
that morphine man it's magic oh man my
guy was right there I don't know little
icon next I was like oh that's the homie
wouldn't ya you can like that you have
to go down you know I mean like I can't
just immediately get out Oh like I'm
wait for that revive so which i think is
cool right it's kind of forcing you to
like at least interact with your team
you know like yeah for when I die is
like hey do you want to wait for a
Reviver he just wants pie I'm like I'm
just gonna spawn again okay I really
care yeah but if you're really strategic
and want to win his conquest matches
better revive your teammates ooh we're
getting in the tank eighteen shelves is
this a tiger yes okay
the biggest German tank or I don't know
like their main tank force
and I lost my happy just got a main gun
I guess Oh
c-can you Oh what we try some of this
out yeah try stupid oh yeah that's that
destruction model in action right there
there showing that off I like this and
oh what's up damn man
savage over here see someone get him oh
come on hey it was that they're hard
they're hardened soldiers man they
trained for tank shells
oh damn I just saw your boy get out of
the tank right there that's pretty cool
thanks for nothing instead of just
popping out the tank yeah
well tough to get over these snow hills
yeah houses ain't no thing but uh snow
it was a hell of a hell of an obstacle
man y'all behind 50 tickets y'all got to
pick it up it's getting desperate now
ceiling take see here don't leave hang
out oh I got to get some homies to the
left I'm not home he's got enemies love
your boy got him capture some points
yeah y'all got see oh we got enemy tank
come on Oh people hit okay okay oh sweet
okay wait who died there
looks like our plane yeah oh wait what
the hell I think I just killed a guy
outside my crap oh we got out we got
some tank battles over here this dude's
got some pretty good cover oh you got
hit with something get me out of here oh
you need a job jump out it's taking a
long time to get out the stink so this
is kind of the same case like you when
you're when you spawn in a vehicle you
don't have like your actual about like
you only have that a lesser second mp40
looks like oh really okay yeah like I
don't have much else I don't think I
have like the tank kit okay so I got I
liked anti-tank mine and repair tool
well I could have repaired that's a lot
of snow for indoors just hang here sure
play the objectives it's important did
you want
man the tickets is this matches getting
out of reach
oh there we go that kill that's always
good
and y'all behind about 45 tickets get
them get get that D get that D captured
that B
I'll get him get again it's all good so
happens about again towards the end of
the match we were ahead hundred some
tickets but we're down about 40 now oh
no we're down about thirty closing the
gap a little bit can we make a
last-minute push [ __ ] okay we got the
majority of objectives over here man
they're the enemy team is real in I
think we can make a comeback closing the
gap
man if you can see if you can nab a few
kills while you got the ticket nine
minutes oh yes
don't kill man 20 tickets go back to D
you still have majority of the flags yes
for now some probably get some kills
revive you homies oh no yes squad
revived Oh see if someone comes a
certain way oh my god they're pushing
their evolution the tickets is closed
it's within ten now 1000 is B I think we
can announce around five Wow closing the
cap real fast at the last minute it's a
tie game now it's anyone's match on
there
I like this over and under type of
bridge you know I mean like yeah God
dude come on alright so we have the lead
now we got the lead bag last minute lead
take over zip Rob could've one match
right there could've been one be five he
could have took them - all down look at
that would have been a done deal we have
a slight lead still 50 tickets left
oh man these tickets is cohen town real
fast man oh it's so close
swap leads about lay five times
throughout the course of this match so
it's coming down to the wire it's
exciting stuff it's a tie game
shotgun shotgun shot
my doing standing Oh was that a v2
rocket or v1 in his hand
no those yeah maybe that's like the end
game of the match like that's how you
know you I totally just went off
now where you come from where you come
from wow this is a really close match
revive somebody's hat damn now
Oh No look at that ticket count I know a
flight that flying like that flying
Sturm Guevara 44 wow it's pretty much
tied oh my doing chin it's so intense
man come on oh my god who's gonna win
the match anyways everybody is there it
is
we won 5 to 0 we start with a ticket
kind of like what 800 or something have
you wind 5 to 0
that's a pretty damn close match it just
typed HH I can't see the keeper with
this Mike good game that was a good game
that was cool yeah that was us some a
little bit of that classic Konquest mode
for everyone out there and we won we won
5 to 0 and I ranked up yeah Oh your
private - oh no you get yet - you get to
corporal look at all those ranks man you
rank it up cool cool
that was some some classic battlefield
gameplay for everyone out there now it's
fun do we maybe chat I mean how long is
that should we move on to check out
operations or sure do more conquest same
map I want to see you I think I want to
see some grand operations in action ok
yeah then we shall all right if y'all
are just joining us right now we're
playing battlefield 5 closed alpha we
just got done with the conquest match
which Rob single-handedly won single
handily damn is pretty good whoo that's
pretty good
it's in writing that down it's early in
the morning but I'm on top of my game
and it is early in the morning let's get
into it
let's check out my assignment here ok
objectives captured 10 done deal that
was an explosive damage as an assault
okay get that heal I what I like
I guess I was more reviving heal allies
for 700 points oh yeah that's the
medical palette sorry I got a drop more
of those pouches we supplied 10 Ella is
a sport I should um I should check out a
support we found sure thing
done that yeah we got our weekly
challenges here it's just one right like
but you can obviously get more Oh its
daily orders I don't know if the special
assignments are weekly but that's a I
don't want to talk about fortnight
that's cool we don't have to stay alive
for two minutes it seems hard for some
players it's pretty easy to do when
you're fine
oh yeah sidearm okay let's do that
let's kill peeps with a I'll pimple
Alvin bet sir hello from the Philippines
but gone dongle Mogga if it's uh it's
the morning time over there
Christopher Brutus you get shout out
what's up Christopher Brutus who's that
oh yeah hey yo can I please yeah yeah
you got a shout out Chris alright okay
we're gonna we're trying to jump it to
some grand operations so if y'all wanted
to throw us some questions about our
experience or Rob's experience with
battlefield 5 do you want to see the
menu as we wait you got the sensitivity
here so sensitive decisive video
settings no saying this video settings
like there's no like bump up that field
of view I'm just kidding more I really
do like 105 but you know do you really
yeah that's too much for me it's looking
like a but now looks like fisheye yeah I
mean I'll change it I like I like that a
wide fov well scum motion blur you got
depth of feel for your weapon oh you
know I did I turned off film grain let's
turn on you can see what I mean I think
it's a little it's a bit much it's a bit
much
okay like you can you can really see the
grain get a little grainy in there yeah
I've never been a fan of film grain I
mean if it's like tasteful John it goes
with any kind of filter right like you
shouldn't be able to notice it the
second you know you see what it is you
know what I mean is like I think that's
when it's too much yeah
like you want to like just a little dab
so we'll drop a little dab no no no no
where we banned dabs around the GameSpot
offices people still do it but um holy
vortex or vortex for vortex yeah said is
bathroo fide battlefield 5 does it take
place in Norway I believe it takes I
mean this is just one map yeah this is
just the one map so far but they will be
taking us around the world
yeah and I think more lesser known yeah
conflicts in world war two so not like
they specifically said like you're not
gonna really be doing any d-day because
yeah that's that's a fair point because
I feel like that has been exhausted
all right we're we're gentlemen so we're
dropped into grand operations here
similar to the operations mode that we
had in battlefield one but with a couple
twists yeah I don't really know I know I
had like a basic understanding of this I
mean I mean it's like a series of
different game modes right like over the
course of days so this just looks like
defend flags really yeah I think it
phase is a mix of objectives so it
varies the game played throughout the
single patch
I love the recoil the recoil on these
weapons are it's like really satisfying
it's like you can feel like the weight
and power
that's territory in Ponte
when it's your name 0 if I recall
correctly operations are thematically
played over a number of in-game days
yeah so but but I've to my understanding
maybe Jack answer this is that like some
like it doesn't always go to the fourth
day it could end on the second like if
we uh I believe if like we loo or we
defend because I feel like the Germans
in the situation are too far on the book
oh where are you going oh my god are on
the on the defense right like if we can
successfully defend day two I believe
the operations ends ok and and we just
can do it all another one I think so
let's see what uh see what everyone and
the chats been talking about everyone
wants some shoutouts oh end of day two
sectors lost or it's like or it's like
you can only go to like day three like
only in some tiebreaker will it go to
like day four I think should know with
our lines intact our forces can safely
move into a more strategic location in
the mountains Oh someone said the squad
leader thing yeah that's how you do the
v1 rocket yeah I guess I'll just have to
hang around until I don't know if I can
like select being a captain it's kind of
like I have to start a new squad or
something right let's see I don't know I
don't know because I don't really play
this game but we're playing it right now
we are so it's a learning process and
let's find out so we're going to this is
cooling it like Northern Lights it like
at aurora borealis good lord what is
that in your kitchen yes grand
operations they are grand and they are
operations day one so I was right okay I
think I was right cuz that we did day
two right
yeah we just start all over again so I
think now we're British okay which is we
paratroop in if you're German you like
have to like get on the entire aircraft
guns we have to as British soldiers
I wasn't me cool all right take out the
entire craft so one cool thing I liked
hearing is that
oh no I'm German again is that they come
in on in parrot in like dc-10
paratrooper planes right okay
they control when they want to get out
so if you want to take that risk and
like pull like a flanking and maneuver
and get behind us you can hang on longer
however you're you're more prone to
getting shot down in yeah yeah well look
at this freaking thing I think this is
really good I just fired it okay oh no I
feel about that that's it
so we're playing grand operations here
in battlefield VE battlefield 5 and on
day one they've got the Allies pair of
tripping it's a port port of Narvik man
they're on the open Oh shipping in cyber
it's got a really sweet spectacle to it
at least on day one agree got a roller
borealis in the background while pair
troops are coming in Delhi s hold me
revive me but I died anyway what can you
do
let's pick that medic like that load out
all right gamespot is a snipe
GameSpot's in the chat saying he's lying
we all dab you're lying we don't
so whoever that might be get off our
account please me you to burn endanger
your back thank you for joining us thank
you everyone for joining us as we are
caught up early in the morning early in
the morning to play some battlefield 5
for everyone nice dope shot man I love
how you to exit the vault oh wow look
like was fused it's like a demolition
type thing going on here again we need
the robber I got to play battlefield 5
during e3 so this is our today is our
first experience with our hands on the
game and Rob seems to be doing quite
well for himself if I could say myself
show yourself
drops the profession
[Applause]
nope
oh I hit a fired it fired it down try to
us try to give you a little uh some
moments to of concentration they're
robbing us did you didn't use it at all
summers keep running my mouth when are
you trying to snipe come on dude wow you
see me parachuters yeah Wow stay in
there
hang in there if there's if there's one
thing that battlefield always gets right
it's a set of a sense of scale it feels
it feels huge even if it's just 32
versus 32 it feels huge
these dudes are like flanking it sounds
so good get it it's got a lot of bass to
it
like this is green shapes along yeah
yeah yeah that's really cool
that I like I could feel it in my book I
could feel it in my bones just little
things like that that make battlefield
step above other
other shooters what in the hell now if
I'm alright
get him oh yes
nice hit on that cart oh you know we
haven't done yet what is like building
[ __ ] oh it is for tonight bill on top of
that man that I know apologize I'm
disappointed that you know where this I
know exactly oh yeah I'm a huge South
Park fan no I kiss can't really see the
same how do I build I don't know dude
dude you don't have to build maybe oh
you can only do in a designated areas
that's right that's why okay like only
at like objectives oh [ __ ] it's not oh
man there see this I'm talking like
they're like we don't have anti-air
going like making it pretty far in yeah
there seems to be there they're making a
push man oh they got some good snipers
out there oh yeah come on he's out -
maybe he was trying to get me you know
[ __ ] not how you address your
teammates 100 rows I do that
nice nice dude nice nice nice airhorn
bring back runways I seen the chat amen
yeah those a lot of fun a lot of wind-up
time though but come on they're making a
push they're making a very very strong
push over here squad white so let's take
a look at squads seen too much not
forgot okay um Oh yep okay so this is
classic so I can just start a new one I
believe everyone's trying to probably do
the exact same thing we are
okay so you got a bunch of so you hey so
you want to be the captain of the SWA
squad in order to I can leave and create
a new squad
I'm better off just joining joining like
George here mr. Iverson mr. version mr.
version like Iverson
[Music]
joint SWAT no they don't let you leave
leave a full squad you know what's funny
is just someone here in the in-game chat
was saying that they're having trouble
joining squads oh that might be it that
might be a little alpha-alpha
problem yeah we got over there but what
it's all good let's come back to it okay
we have uh we have a battle to fight
over here amen well a battlefield to be
on oh we got your oh yeah the pair 43 oh
yeah Oh
go get them that's a nice my instinct is
to lead but it is moving quite slow that
hefty plane okay
what if taking those down they can go
down before they oh now I'm hitting it
I'm just so far away
oh boy Wow very nice watch you're fine
another vehicle destroyed Wow what's
working oh there's a yeah there's a
short short range that it has explosions
is it the only we'll only one map yes
only one map so far in the closed alpha
wow wow you took a lot of 74 damage over
there quick minutes she's throwing him
yeah we only have one one map it's an RV
and we have two modes though at least
conquests and we're playing grand
operations right now this is day one of
our grand operation I think this will
look so much better on PC at all
I mean like because this is I feel like
this isn't max settings where I'm
staying all right right
so I was very clear we are playing on PC
by the way I was not it's it's been an
early morning its yeah Rob is here 1
a.m. despite what he says he was here at
1 a.m. oh this guy oh you see his a
scope yeah I did a little shyness
down the open here
look all these guys yeah here you go
we got a friend Moomin in the chat I
assume single player will be like bow
fill one yes they're doing war stories
similar to Battlefield one I think
they're rolling them out at a slower
rate like yeah like every few months is
like chronologically story yeah yeah
like I believe like their their plan as
far as like a full year for battlefield
5 is to have maybe like every couple
months a new front or a new campaign or
like a new country entering the war so
like right now we are just seeing I
believe you just start as I'm fairly
sure that when the game launches it's
just maybe Germany vs. pretty British
dollars as far as the two conflicts go
yeah like the two factions available and
then they start rolling out like you
know the French enter the war or like
Americans in the war along with like
their weapons and vehicles yeah in a way
they're trying to like create this tale
of content that fronto chronologically
kind of follows and tells the story of
World War two and everything is free
they set straight up that they're not
having any paid DLC so all about content
updates everything they're rolling out
it's gonna be free and available to
everyone who buys the game so I think
that's kind of an interesting
interesting approach and keeps okay yeah
it keeps people playing I think the idea
it really is to keep people playing for
longer yeah or at least keep coming back
which is so it's a little very much like
a hot a hot bike trend lately right you
wanna you want to create some sort of
game as a service so you have people
constantly coming back rather than drop
in an entire game on them day one and
then you know having a peter out right
like a perfect example is what you guys
off has been doing with a lot of its
games right like just siege
having such longevity and a strong
player blade playerbase like after the
fact
yeah I think they could pull that off
it's almost like an episodic type of
wall out I would say and we've seen that
work with my hitman but plus eight man
it's a very different game by nature but
I kind of like that yeah something
something to look forward to pick
yourself up soldier hopefully there's
enough at launch though I actually don't
know what the launch package is gonna
look like yeah that's that's the only
concern right I'd like it like if if
they find themselves spreading
themselves too thin yeah you wanna you
want a strong base game on day one of
course all right and then roll
everything out else out as time goes on
that'd be cool who knows we'll find out
what October only got October 26 this
game I think so it's like it's like
those those three weeks in October like
last year or almost every year now it's
like a Call of Duty a battlefield or a
Battlefront and I don't know October 9
October 19 is the the worldwide release
for Battlefield 5 but I think that if
you have origin access you'll get a week
early access to game a week early as
they usually do with EA games if you're
a member of origin access or EA access
depending on the platform
sorry I want to say we're doing a pretty
good job at I've been paying attention
to the gameplay all that much but it
seems a little little difficult to keep
track of what stage how well you're
doing maybe that's just me that's why
just me cuz I'm a dumbass no it's fair I
believe I believe we're just we're just
trying to defend ourselves for as long
as that ticker is in the top mid left so
I want to say we have a minute 30 20
left
dusty drawers I like the Northern Lights
in the skyline for battle yeah it looks
it's a amazing spectacle looks what's
great while you're doing some bad stuff
drama some guy that humble canoe is like
GG maybe I can't tell you just said it
yeah so I guess I'm the I'm not the only
one who can really tell what's going on
or what the status is of the battle no
I'm utterly confused so he if he's
staying that we didn't win it looked
like we did you won what you didn't win
so what what phases is going to it was a
draw on day one half the objectives were
secured we're loading
oh man what's gonna happen next
yeah it's only been an hour oh boy
you've been in here for about four hours
oh dude I haven't you hanging in there
man yeah yeah I'm great
okay day 2 day 2 of Robbie a miserable
day - I've sold myself the port of
Narvik Norway there having voted - ever
needing cheeto dust
my friends don't text me anymore
my mother she hates me oh I don't call
her anymore I just play battlefield ok
survivors from the previous day we got
10 extra tickets I imagine those are
tickets depending on I guess depending
on how you do how well you do on day one
factor it well yeah factors into your
status on day 2 so it's a constant
battle throughout the days which i think
is a pretty pretty cool though matically
yeah it's cool it's neat you know it's I
like I think the benefit is that it's
just another mode to play and give it a
shot yeah like I for one I'm just gonna
play convoys probably all day I think
let's be real let's be real
oh nice or should you like smeared
turtle of yourself anyway the gate
status here oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
sweet nice shot you see I just yelled
sorry for years listening everyone who
has ears out there listening to this
stream Rob is killing your eardrums
there's also killing fools on the
battlefield I am you didn't even have to
bust a shot and you got a kill man I
didn't fire how did that happen - that's
alpha am i right
it's cuz ice is it cuz I spotted him
maybe you like gave me a it gave me an
audio cue that I'd like maybe the guy
you you thought you killed got revived
and then someone else killed them and
then did I use my mind I don't know yeah
you maybe you're right
it's like I'll give you I'll give that
kill back or something I don't know
that's fine maybe it's an alpha I'm a
superhero oh yeah oh yeah Rob's Rob's
got that power man man these guys are
storming Christopher Brutus need to get
some breakfast BRB yeah
if y'all if y'all haven't got something
yet make sure you stay nutrify nutrition
had a nutritious yeah yeah get some grub
in you
oh so the I think these guys fortified
here cuz yeah That's not me
that guy got real fortified
what's this get down get down on it I
wish I could just peek out without
without having to look scoped yes
because that will happen fail that's
pretty sweet I got shot the head pull
out the bass hole you better you better
dude look at this guy damn that's cold
this is cooked that is straight I was
rude that is straight murder right there
your your your homie is just as much to
blame for that kill as the guy actually
shot you that's straight
he'll know he'll know who he is hey
revived me but baby come on man revive
revive our friend Rob cat over here dude
he had a bug face if you out there
playing bow field five on this server
make sure you revive Rob cat it's a good
man I think from what I know at least
cheater you're a cheater you're getting
called cheater
all right we're reporting you Rob we saw
that we have it live on air and I'm a
hacker that was so weird that mine to
kill it was so weird
oh oh that's a tank coming yep I got I'm
not very well equipped I'm not quite
sure what this sparring will do so get a
nice get a close look at everyone out
there oh my god
I don't know I'm doing let's go back to
assault you know I'm gonna get that
Rob's losing steam here we got to revive
him in real life Rob thanks doc I feel
way better get me back in there all
right we just revived Rob I think he's
guys he's got some extra juice in them
let's go Panzer fast you're play
Wolfenstein yeah Castle yes and you
could abort it so like in like all the
spawners be like Return to Castle
Wolfenstein man that was another another
great multiplayer game that I played
when I was young
does my first xbox live game actually
yeah so that was a big deal for me
because I oh god damn it there you go
suck it
that was scary Oh hide in the trees
trees that vehicles down down in help
one shot to get home oh come on I think
it's already someone else's frightened
last minute oh look at that floating
soldier Wow distracted by the by the
alpha bugs true distraction alpha bug
did you damn these Brits man they know
it's all right is it this same dude
again damn dude does not care I think it
is skull I think cuz he's in your squad
so you're gonna see him a lot he should
be green though okay I don't think I'm
in a squad oh you're all by me oh maybe
I can do it you aren't a squad I am as
your own Queen your Queen Rob hey
McQueen I want to get out of this and
joints get the dog get into dog with all
your dogs yeah that sounds good join
that I can't psych you're in your own
squad what if they're purposely doing
that I don't they're trying to test
something out there with squads or just
like straight up yeah don't have the
capability it seems it seems odd yeah if
you're watching out there my just joint
squads come on let's have friends
oh yeah you know I want to do the other
thing they don't have and this is the oh
the attachment like you could take a
tank yeah having I've not seen that in
action yet I wonder if you can't do that
I just maybe there has a bit of use case
for it quite yet in these matches but I
am interested in seeing that yeah me too
move in thank you plain I don't want to
wreck this guy rectum trying to get your
your panzerfausts tell ya my pans wrong
in [ __ ] the pans are off kinda chatty
was up he's like the lack of squad we
Biden is making me sad yep same
and if you see you can see your friend
down and now is the time to pick them up
got a pickup pick up the friends man
save them tickets it's all about tickets
so much time with towing mechanics like
oh yeah I like I don't know I want to
say in conquest I've seen jeep icons cuz
that's that's the only thing I can
imagine you can do with a tank but I
think Oh for the yeah for towing the
anti-air guns or the turrets or whatever
mm-hmm hmm let's go here
again this is uh this is the battlefield
5 alpha so if you see something weird
going on like that fools I hope he's all
right man I think he's okay
safety measures on these planes was
top-notch back in the day so how [ __ ]
you got you got an enemy just hanging
out under the bridge you know I hate
that guy don't we yeah like I'd like to
be in a squad so I can spawn on my squad
so some yeah it'd be cool and like half
friends it's cool to have friends it's
totally cool that friends but you ain't
got none so you're on your own man
yeah come on y'all need to fix that uh
squatting up maybe maybe there's just a
problem in whatever this game what's
call again
grant operation and operations yeah but
you're having the same problem in uh
conquests Oh was I yeah I think we were
trying to break out into another squad
earlier and that wasn't letting us so
that was cool
yeah do that again do that again nope
nope you can either penny on running
start like here maybe Oh God nope
it's all good your friend got your backs
but he won't revive you the least got my
balls protect you he's got my back until
him dead or down hello
what are you waiting for this guy there
it is
we'll get him right in the chest man oh
this guy Oh anyone this game Oh hope
he's alright
oh this game don't get revived - oh just
a hit just he could still get revived
just imagine getting a like that like an
88 black shell right into the chest you
know you'd think it'd be hard to revive
someone hey but you stick stick a
syringe in his shoulder he can EBI it oh
is our tank coming he's come down this
road please come on this road
oh yeah come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
Oh what an [ __ ] plane did it if I
shoot this plane out of the sky I swear
to God would be the happiest little boy
come over here
no boy coming back for me he's come back
for me I don't have get lower get lower
damn what's going on here
flare I probably get off this huh um no
I think we're good
you're useful man I spend the rest of
this stream just doing this yeah sure
yeah I mean this is this is my favorite
thing to do I get hella good at this
[ __ ] they're doing their job I got an
idea he knows he wants this you're gonna
try a head-on with the with the Panzer
yes all right we'll see how that works
out dude
I will give you like 50 million dollars
if you hit this dude with the panzer 50
million dollars
y'all heard it here first all right now
man I'm in debt $10 great great work rob
was wrong man that made my day
dude that guy just probably went trying
to come back and get this I give it a
man you just got just got blowed up live
on gamespot that's all right oh man dude
that was awesome ha
I'll remember that that was that was
some battlefield ass yeah there you know
what I mean like all right that's some
classic battle Peter right there right
this guy's like harassing me I'm gonna
show him what's up
that's all that's a classic battlefield
[ __ ] oh come on that's also some
classic battlefield [ __ ] right there
yeah oh man that was good I enjoyed that
thank you rob now do it again for
another 50 million dollars oh man House
fine that was cool all right we reached
the we peaked so everything else from
here there's sound delay Oh No
is there a problem with audio let us
know if not keep watching if there is
keep watching anyway oh man I want to
see that I want to see that highlight so
bad like he was so far away oh my God
look at it well we'll clip that well
he'll clip that and we'll send it out to
the world that was freakin amazing hey
that those that's cool okay oh man I'm
glad to have been part of that Rob fun
yeah do killcam in this i haven't
noticed at all because if there was that
was that I would have looked at it ooh
boy what what an excellent battlefield
moment yes indeed I'm so glad I hit that
everyone's calling me out for my 50 min
this [ __ ]
oh sweet oh my god and any got a
promotion hotshot in back and a
promotion yeah man that was that was
pretty sweet that's some classic
battlefield [ __ ] right there - we
should be saying that the whole time
yeah I don't feel this is a battlefield
ass right here at least we know that the
series is intact man that's one of my
favorite things about bill - just like
running up to tanks throwing a bunch of
c4 running away blowing it up it's very
satisfying yeah
oh man still trying to catch my breath I
know me too that mom my heart's gift
yeah I didn't I didn't think I was gonna
land my bank accounts can I have to
catch his breath
- you want to dot me Rob yes god I just
love that that felt like it wasn't even
the shot it was just that guy like he
did just like three strafing runs on me
yeah like still trying at you still
couldn't get me being a pain in my ass
and you showed him who's boss I showed
him to check herself and then he rectums
and then he wrecks himself
damn you wrecked him I did with the end
of my rocket fire sorry I forgot to aim
down sights for that
I thought Julie I thought she was a pro
at that I'm super good with it
[Music]
dan we should just just close the stream
man we can't we can't top that can't top
that oh man that's cool chat like that
I'm glad I'm glad everyone out there got
to got to witness greatness you are in
debt my friends for life yeah you know
what you just you just got me you bought
me a beer tonight or something like that
all right yeah fifty million dollar beer
fifty mil dollar beer man CBS
Interactive I know y'all I'll pay the
big bucks so make it happen oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ] guy excuse you watch your mouth
boy Oh
oh hell yeah light him up got a little
lane right there and I want to give it
away of that I want to think it's safe
down this quarter Oh
do it so well check yeah it's very I
noticed the aiming for that
this guy's misguided going prone
thinking you can get a shot up oh that's
grenade actually good okay is that
trying to simulate what it's like to
have the machine gun on a swivel or
something or is it just like chops [ __ ]
it's just the degrees of turner are are
skipping whoa
let it rain bullets hey you got to it's
not bad
oh yeah the thing was looking a little
choppy when you're trying to swing it
around but you know it's an alpha alpha
I'm alright alright I like like we
mentioned earlier and like the chat was
saying after they are not the the Chad
but the in-game chat was saying after
day one how do we know we're making
progress in these objectives to be
completely honest yeah I forgot I always
be playing operations here yeah you were
just trying to get some kills man oh
that should do the the linking or look
like maybe he was doing at that back it
up and dump it boy excuse me
yeah where is he getting this I don't
even see it as an icon
that's a fine armored car won't you back
that thing up do you think you do that
you think that guy in the plane like
just turned off the game and like by
unstoppable in went to bed contact DEA
said alright can you take my clothes out
Bucky and give to somebody else as I
applying this [ __ ] no more
I cannot report robbed can also also can
i play
oh hell yeah is he doing good some get
some flank action on these are they
still up on that yeah damn it
Manson in freaking broad daylight there
I think a bunch of fools are still up on
that railway want to flank them but that
fool flanked you it's a it's a
never-ending series of flanks in
battlefield
it's how being at least there's a little
less getting shot in the back like Call
of Duty yeah not too big on that even in
like call duties like conquests or
whatever I think it's called control or
some [ __ ] yeah for sure like I feel like
that's a lot of the battlefield deaths
or like you you find yourself blaming
yourself a little bit more for a little
bit more yeah like I'm just not paying
attention
like I'm not what what am i doing over
the years I think that spawning at least
in the battle food series spawning has
kind of been improved little by little
oh I may as well say do we have another
victim see there that choppiness the
plants yeah pet the Gucci goose that's
uh my boy this guy's legit Gucci goose I
like that name in it to win it I think
I'll take it
Oh No yay
but robbing a squad please I guess we've
taken take a two flags and this is
game-mode
again the semantic some objective points
that boy only my god what they threw my
mixtape alphas are about core mechanics
and stability right right
crayon eating technical crayon eating
horrible let's get it ends yeah I like
that
I really I really like
we have a floating car 98 over there a
lot of floating weapons we saw the
flying German Gewehr 44 earlier just
floating in the air don't fly him low
wasn't the tower
drop it low like it's money on the phone
let's go back to America drop it low
like it's money on the flow
we're still this is still our first our
first yeah this is our first match of
grant operations so we still in it yo
this is almost going on for about I'd
say 40 minutes yeah we've been at this
grant operation for about 40 minutes man
so if you're gonna be playing this mode
you're gonna have to be in it for the
long haul you want to see it to the end
oh sweet 1.4 a vehicle hit that plane
are you guys going
Oh what you gotta hit him multiple times
with the prepare 43 got him 100 SF will
select you as an mp40
you're bleeding out nice I always got a
sweet view of the mountains what a way
to die
looks beautiful though I was actually it
does I was in Canada last week in
Connelly oh that's right how was that
trip it was I got the III flew in the
middle of my trip that was wonderful
yeah did watch outdoor stuff still if we
thrown up would have was about to I had
I had a like a really bad fever on my
second day there's like you just
couldn't necessarily do much yeah I
could do much for about three or four
days that sucks yeah I did what I can no
sure it was it was some good medicine at
least being in the outdoors oh oh the
end of day two zero out of three sectors
lost we did good oh it's dead
day two attitude so I'm wondering if a
lot I'm wondering if this particular map
port of Narvik is only day two days or
if there's a condition in which there's
a third day or is it just like straight
up two days so this is going to how cool
and finally Anna oh no no this is just
saying the best squad you know be dope
is it the best squad was just you since
you know all by herself and they should
mmm what I was thinking is like what if
they have play of the game
I know battlefield is too big of a
battle to get down a play of the game
but if we did have a play of the game in
that Panzer kill man you know it how
could what kind of like I know what you
would call it like how would how would
they even be able to like register that
play of the game you know what I mean
cuz what was significant about it like
it was tight that's what I mean any
radar like what's the algorithm to
determine I think like didn't didn't
Blizzard kind of do a little a patent on
their play the game or something what
was the specific part of the patent was
it just like no idea the name of it who
are we gonna be British now no I think
you're still that'd be a bummer axis
look at this yeah that's nice that's
lame why can't we switch sides
yeah
I don't want to do this all again do you
want to jump out of this yes and then
see if you can jump into another match
and see if you can be British because
that would be that would be cool to see
right yeah what it's like to be on day
one maybe jumping out of planes and
stuff maybe we can get that yeah all
right so will you've been that we've
been at it for about an hour and a half
playing battlefield five closed alpha if
if you have been joining us recently or
just now battlefield 5 closed alpha rob
has been at it for quite some Jo Oh - I
want to play cool all right
um sorry this muscle will sweaty after
that Panzer fashion shot yeah even the
mousepad sweaty II what are you doing
wrong it's good its healthy sweat
I guess all right we're gonna do a
little switch switch over here yeah you
don't want mine okay it's this room man
it's not Meads it's it's a hot stuffy
room and we'll stop talking about it
because I don't what's going on here
yeah I'm running out of breath so Rob
you can take over speak to the chat I
wasn't doing too good of a job of
keeping our eye on chat man I'm sorry to
everyone if y'all had questions out
there you can repeat them and Rob maybe
we can pull them out for y'all you know
I did what I can but I was very excited
to watch Rob wreck some noobs reckon
fools that was fun this has been fun
it's been a great stream hope you guys
are doing great
yeah it's Thursday I think Thursday is
my favorite day of the week especially
because today is your birthday clothes
clothes today
might as well be ours payday that is
Mazda be birthdays wait whose is whose
Oh what'd you get what'd you get I got a
white mocha they look the same
does that look like yours I'm pretty
sure mine was the furthest away that's
what I grabs okay obviously you already
grabbed it yeah
all right we're good we could we Gucci
whatever all right I think we've got we
actually might need a close this is not
looking like a healthy menu let me cut
away from the gameplay and do you want
to do you want it let's let's do um it's
not that sweaty in here it's just it's
to see if you look real so you look pink
as hell
Thanks I look do just force quit this
okay all right hang in there guys we'll
be right back okay let's do a little
after-action review of your you played
you're playing a little bit earlier but
you played about an hour and a half live
on stream but that's how you feel about
an hour earlier than that okay so about
two and a half hours with the clothes
out though so they'll tab out I don't
know I'll do all that for nice how I
feel I feel like it's it's fluid it
feels good I think the guns feel
noticeably like heavier with more recoil
which I got some weight to them they got
some weight I think aesthetics are I
mean that you know that's always been a
staple with dice and they're even
Battlefront for that matter I think that
these games you know this is not a final
product that still looks great
playing on PC I'm into it especially
especially as someone who's been with
the series for pretty much since its
inception sure you would have me that I
didn't play much of like bad company or
in like for like three more okay feel
three but yeah I mean are see if I could
if I could say anything but the last
hour and a half is uh I just I just
think about that one moment battlefields
all about those moments man those are
always good moments I remember
especially in 1942 you got on that plane
you got like for your for your squad
mates to hop onto the wings of that
plane you fly that those dumb
fun right dumb fun yeah a bloke who gets
a Panzer kill on a damn airplane it's
dumb fun I'm fun there's always gonna be
dumb fun in battlefield games so we got
a little taste of that
and yeah that's not going away with
battlefield 5 I know some are might be
concerned with if not if it's going to
retain some of that some of that dumb
magic that we get from the battlefield
games and yeah that's still there mmm
absolutely yeah I mean the only things
that like you know it's a guys it's
close alpha I guess isn't done yet but
like the biggest the issue with like the
vehicles they seemed a little jank
okay yeah I know that maneuvering a tank
was a little little tough yeah Matt as
well yeah I would really want to see
that towing mechanic hopefully we can
like try that or see it yeah if I got a
chance I'll see what I can do with that
but yeah yeah all right we're trying to
find a grand Operations match over here
we're about a minute and a half into
finding a match so we'll see if we'll
have any luck again this is an alpha so
expect some jank just testing this out
and again there's only one map for both
conquests and operations same map just
sort of Narvik yeah okay who is a towel
for eyes chill out my man hey we're
trying we're trying we're trying you
want to sit here and just talk I mean I
do I left I'm with Michael but one of us
we're waiting yeah we're waiting it's
about a two minute it's been two minutes
I think roughly four okay cool yeah I've
been I've been with the battlefield
series as well I mentioned before since
1942 since its inception and I've been
with it continually ever since about
dropped off about after I would say
after 2142 picked it back up with a bad
company - I hear a lot of great things
with that game yeah yeah it's a I didn't
play too much of it as much as other
people but I definitely saw what was
valuable in that game it's better than
the single player that single player was
pretty fun and I think that's when kind
of destruction models became a really
big thing in the in the series Dolan
yeah and it's we've seen it evolve ever
since
bad company and we've kind of we reached
an evolution or well this is kind of the
the top evolution we've seen thus far
for the battlefield game as we see
buildings crumble as the tanks roll
through them yeah and I mean that and
that's another thing with this game
right is the ability to rebuild more or
less with sandbags and trenches and
stuff that's something we should also
maybe try to do yeah I'll see if I can
get into that is that that's not
restricted to any class anyone could do
that anyone can do it you just can only
do it in certain areas like flags or I
want to say objective areas I'm not
that's as far as my knowledge goes okay
yes massacre 1080 in twitch chat
I am reading both YouTube and twitch so
yeah just have any questions chat is
just moving a little quick so I'm gonna
I guess I can jump into conquest if
we're having trouble yeah just do that
yeah we're having a little trouble
trying to get into a grand Operations
match just now again this is a closed
alpha so we may run into problems and we
apologize if we do well we're trying to
get into a match so sit tight and yeah
and if you're watching on I think if
you're watching it YouTube you can do a
little rewind if you want rewind it
about half an hour look for a look for
the part where we get really excited I
missed that
all time stamp it later I'll have some
okay like maybe Ryan will do it after
the vaad or sorry the vaad goes up so
this whole stream will stop
oh quick break has a question go for it
you just say it you don't have to ask if
you have a question yeah just hit us
with your questions hopefully we can
spot them out and give them an answer
AHA Wow killer 84 says what are the
biggest differences similarities between
this about field one it's it's hard to
explain I'm not I feel like I'm not very
articulate and I was articulate
sometimes I came to say that word
battlefield one in comparison to this
with movement it this feels this feels
far better as far as like clambering and
busting through doors busting out of
windows like you fuel you feel stronger
and more agile in this game and it's it
feels great like it actually gives me
it gives me a feel of like titanfall 2
which is when my favorite games all-time
like the mobility in that game like you
you yeah you can cheat death if you are
able to like hard enough within your
environment and yeah like the the
movement model allows you to utilize
your environment because like sometimes
in battlefield 1 it's like okay I have
the I've been this building and I see
all these obstacles and stuff but it's a
little hard to get around them and kind
of use them to my advantage because of
the way the movement model was albeit
with it was pretty good in battlefield 1
but here from watching you it seems like
you're you have a more you're more
capable of utilizing your environment
yeah as you move it's more comfortable
it feels far more comfortable yeah
especially peeking out a cover and
creeping around like I do feel a
difference there
[Music]
yeah hundred percent someone asked about
videos so there's not much someone asked
about video options there's not a whole
lot like I can't change any kind of what
would you call them like textures and
shadows like that's not available yet
because this is again closed alpha yeah
so I guess it does like an auto detect
depending on your hardware for the most
part is that how they normally this type
of alpha would operate i would imagine
because you know if i'm running like a
1050 TI i don't want to run high
textures or i'm not gonna have the same
fidelity as someone who's running like a
1070 right here yeah goatman 42 is now
online Oh John Luke what's up man I
don't know what's going on with yes this
sucks
this match is taking a lot longer than
it was earlier let me see there we go oh
that's the thing did someone drop a
bunch of utensils that's what it sounds
like alright y'all about to see me in
action hell yeah
no promises you're good you're good well
um hope I answered your question will
great on the PC options
heyo says goal babba 96 what's up hi
join us
we'll have loot boxes apparently you
will not have loot boxes nope no loot
boxes all progression will be natural
natural
Christopher Brutus you got a question I
want to hear it uh we might have an
answer no promises though is there any
point to leveling up I know battlefield
one had done czar bought so that's the
one thing that it's hard to tell in this
is you know as if you've been watching
like I've ranked up to what corporal
maybe past that I'm not getting any
rewards out of it but to my
understanding it's point the coins
beautiful point very similar to be if
one but I don't think it'll take the
form of loot boxes I believe it's the
currency I mean I believe it's all
catered to like customization like
loadouts yeah scopes mods and stuff sure
to your guns Sprint's but we don't see
that because there's only like a handful
of guns
[Music]
video in this alpha now would answer
your question zesty zesty but sizzle can
you customize your soldier you can
there's like a whole like you have like
an option to customize your whole
company so like your planes your certain
your different types of classes you can
get like very specific with how they
look but that's not available in this
close o alpha well boys I am reading
comments late people are saying just
play alright I'm not as seasoned as Rob
this is my okay who'd your good I just
want to shout out real quick is my very
first time playing back five and that's
fine and guess what that's how I was
you're so good I got to live up to
standard decent well you're not gonna
call off that shot I were down by 200
tickets I dropped into a match and it
looks like my my team is not doing so
hot but you know what I'm a stick with
them so I'm not gonna abandon my squad
no matter how much they are behind look
at these little floaties right here we
got floating mines got a lot on my mind
can you make fans
I don't yes I want to say yes you
probably can later on this is just you
know test alpha shoot the grenade in
midair do you know that you can do that
really
yeah oh no how dare you kill me I
believe you can pick up grenades in
throw them back I haven't done yet that
would be I would probably panic it's
very much if that happened
man good rats game journalism I write
there will be early access for Xbox it
just like there was for battlefield one
I will I believe it's like oh it's
almost a week early I think yeah it's a
it'll be a week or like I have made lays
I think yeah something like that
Mad Dog 50 67 Mad Dog of Shimano we all
you yeah cos the fans out there
capturing got play the objectives man
Jesus Garcia asked does this game have
battle royale they have announced it
it's not whether it's gonna be available
at launch is I believe questionable by
I'm that they are working on their that
scare me
I got ski like that's something that I
would I would say he's different from
balcan one like they're like they
they've like push that the aesthetics of
this game a little bit further with like
the screen shaking you don't I mean like
little things little things like that
yeah they're minor but like they're they
have a profound impact yeah they all
kind of add up to have this yeah it
feels a lot more this like feels like
there's more weight to your actions for
sure
gosh my squats man you will be able to
customize your guns oh I got a
panzerfausts let's put that to use boy
e/wd dart you've done son oh I have to
do nothing loud man festival says call
for you up call for revive very
interesting I agree
but what's very interesting as well is
when people refuse to revive you does
anyone in this and anyone now can revive
yes the only issue is that it's slower
than a medic so a medic is just still
have some
important play at the vault and they can
throw med packs make to a med packs all
right we got got our orders to get to D
we got to get that D what Jesus Garcia
says shutout from Los Angeles what's up
Los Angeles LA we see out here live from
San Francisco shots out to LA oh I'm
just gonna chill here and get the
objective me of course I need to help
help my squad to actually get it though
can't just camp man I'll watch it watch
it watch this flank psyched yeah that
tank did just vanish
but we'll see you know like this is
again closed alpha like the the D
spawning of wreckage could be longer
ain't done yet this is available on
Steam it's not origins we are lucky
enough to have closed alpha access this
game for you guys you will there be
awesome gun skins we've seen a little
bit like when you get out of a vehicle
you kind of take on automatically I got
tamed class or like a pilot class which
is the same for about field one had that
there we saw like an mp40 with like a
camo skinny yeah so and they've already
confirmed that like there will be tons
of customization for
nice revive my boy hey oh man
I don't know if you cuz I haven't done
that actually now I think about it is
revive someone while not being a medic
oh yeah I guess there's a prompt yeah I
was didn't see it it's quite
presumptuous than that
I'm always looking out for my my friends
but apparently that was not to my
advantage
unfortunately we don't have any alpha
codes to get or to give out that being
said I know down the road there will be
a closed beta and then there's an open
beta and it's possible that we might
have codes for the closed beta in the
coming month or months no promises
though but well we'll definitely let you
guys know if you follow us on Twitter or
Facebook come on man
can you fly battleships I don't think so
that's a good question I don't I don't
think so all right I'm trying to take
the bailout spam out that damn that's
what hope he's alright he's joking
I think he's faking it oh yeah man not
doing so hot but you know what trying to
get play some objectives over here hey
man wanna be useful hey I'm uh I kinda
know what I'm doing
CBS Interactive for y'all they keep us
to keep us safe out here oh thanks
thanks would in the chat some what it
would say you you can relax type I knew
there was there was a catch to the
reviving anyone okay they have to be in
your squad
oh okay so anyone in your squad you can
revive five all right
which is again incentivizing being in a
squad yes it kind of sucks for you when
you were all by yourself that during
that uh operations mode right good point
well man you took like half health there
then I call so real life it's uh don't
want to be doing that now Oh someone's
trying to take our train What's Up boy
What's Up boy
what do you add um okay I was getting
real scared man no one's gonna no one
could take our D that's all true no
one's gonna take our B all right come on
I'll protect the be till the day I die
oh my god do it loading bay that is my
squad objective - so squad leaders can
give objectives as a per use when it
comes to battlefield we must protect
this house
this house fly fly fly fly says Machine
Gun Kelly oh you want me to fly now
that's gonna be interesting if you if
you get it well maybe later what time is
it will be here for some time we'll get
into a plane again cuz I I agree with
you Machine Gun Kelly I would like to
see something more flying yes you just
toss me that controller if you want me
to fly cuz I'm I could fly okay I'm
pilot pilot Rob you could be my you be
my heist man actually you could be
maverick I'll be Iceman okay that's my
Val Kilmer Cola Falcon were right he's
ice sea ice man I watched Top Gun in a
very long time can you finish off people
asking for a revive I believe so I don't
think you can like if when you kill an
enemy they go down for revived I don't
yeah maybe right I did it didn't seem
like there were a couple times I felt
like I was trying to shoot I was down
and it didn't have any impact yeah maybe
you're right maybe that I mean if you
also consider the the revive how short
it is
yeah like you wouldn't want to expedite
that anymore
mmm-hmm that could be a balancing thing
that guy I think it's I think it's a
little too short you think I don't know
I think if you can't shoot down people
who are in the revives or in a down
state I guess that making it short makes
it so that you know people who get those
sniper kills aren't always like oh man
well I'm gonna supply bother sniper know
if he's gonna have like 15 seconds to
get revived so I kind of under s I kind
of understand yeah and that's a good
point and also you wouldn't want to like
you wouldn't want to like cuz you're
being forced to go into that down state
you wouldn't want to like sit on that
for that much longer right if they were
to balance it in any direction it
wouldn't be much more no planes no boys
oh man we already got some pilots out
there all right I got the Gewehr 43 in
my hands you see if I can do anything
with this I usually go for the mid to
long range semi-auto weapons
two games see if I can do any damage
with them let's cap some objectives
purse whoa excuse me I hope you're all
right man
yeah I'm fine you your rotors are still
going man all right damn play my mixtape
over there I was tight
whoa we got some enemies over here
trying to take over our territory way
all that worry all that no looks like
I'm not doing any damage today
don't touch my friend oh my god I'm so
trash Mike what's up sock sham Malta
good to see you I hope Wolverine is in
this game since sponsorship I'm dreaming
to how Captain America subpoena me to
throw that shield around boy I was
actually watching a Captain America
first first adventure the other night
for some reason don't ask me why but
Chris Evans oh boy looking like a snack
this image models are still weak I agree
that plane rolling around didn't look
too hot but Oh see I you know it again
here's to hoping that they have
fix's yeah final maybe they're working
on it I'd be surprised that wasn't
addressed we need Soviets I'm sure we're
gonna get Soviets man I'm sure we're
gonna get all that all the factions all
the countries yeah like we said earlier
they're the planning on rolling out new
content and stuff like new feeders of
the war as time goes on so we're also
not sure exactly what's gonna be coming
in the base package hope there's enough
there to keep us interested before they
start rolling out there they're DSC free
DLC by the way they're not gonna ask you
to pay for any of the content that
they're gonna roll out so that's uh it's
cool it's good to know I don't mind
about I really don't mind
microtransactions as long as they're
just cosmetic right yeah and you know
it's it's at launch I would I would hope
for just a bunch of maps right that's
what you would want yeah maps over
different like sides yeah not just maps
but maps that kind of encourage you to
play it differently because I think one
of the things that with games like this
is that you can throw in a whole bunch
of maps but if you don't really change
the way you're supposed to play that's
the one I kind of start to drop interest
rather quickly because I know like her
earlier battlefield games had different
different terrains different setups for
vehicles and stuff like that and I think
that's that's what I
I would also want some kills too because
I am not playing so hot once you sicced
on the gentleman's yeah yeah oh yeah
play the play the objective that's what
I'm there for man hashtag Chris Evans
looking like a snake
oh that's me it's me can you make a
soldier that I don't know if that means
soldier that what that what yeah what
someone have a question if I get chopped
in this side Captain America
microtransaction haulin it with a shield
sprinting in the combat had a cute
little outfit red white blue outfit sup
boy what do you at okay I should buy
stop worrying about him start worrying
about objectives we must protect this
house someone else about can you play
this close alpha unfortunately no you
need to have a code ei was nice enough
to give us one for the sake of the
stream but that being said there will be
an open beta down the road I want to say
that generally is maybe August I don't
know I want to say just a few months
prior to release in October so I want to
say that would be August you can try out
battlefield that makes sense
sorts of homie I know it's not hey
Deacon moss good to see you man
if y'all watch it in the chat man I need
to need to I need y'all's help I need
some encouragement I need some good
words from all you good people out there
watching us on GameSpot trying to play
this battlefield 5 closed alpha pyro
maniac says they're the you were 43 I
think that's what you're using yep
Gewehr 43 it's been a massive Gewehr yes
I suppose that is the proper
pronunciation of this weapon in
particular one of my favorite guns to
use in world war ii FPS games I do like
my powerful semi-auto lot mid to long
range rifles especially when they got a
little scopes on them it looks like
we're about to secure objective F but we
have some perpetrators on the perimeter
i'ma try and get two haven't had too
much luck but we'll see what I can do
here I know there's a fool around the
corner over here you got it couple perps
[Music]
good oh no every time you call for
revive this fool is just like screaming
man Oh squats one yes squad spawn is
awfully convenient no commie Haley says
hey Michael its Rob from SD Rob Rob Rob
that's marina's that's my boy he says
get them kills hey I can't rot raba not
you but well actually no no so Rob in
the chat my good friend from San Diego
and you were one of my one of my first
friends when I moved here in San
Francisco so I appreciate y'all
encouraging me to live it up in the Bay
Area so a Rob I'll try and get some
kills for you man but no promises game
journalism all right again okay we can
some make this
Jack Jack deal oh yes gun yeah maybe
this is not the best gun for this
situation in particular but oh he did oh
cool we got a capture oh but there's
still some perpetrators on the perimeter
like this dude
let's get it anybody else in here oh
there is ah these I think these dudes is
like continually spawning on each other
so it's like really hard to get rid of
them
yeah oh but we got that I got the kill
assist so I think they revived me
where's my hobbies a man named Justin
Felder we have not seen the
customization it will be in the game but
this closed-off uh does not have yeah
they're not gonna let us do any of that
I think throughout the Alpha yeah more
just testing out make sure how the game
how the game runs
and seems to be running quite fine with
a little bit of some technical hitches
every here and there
[Laughter]
I do remember that machine gun heli
sorry I'm late machine gun Haley says if
you fly I will sub alright that's okay
fair I'll take it I'll take it I'll see
what I can do after this no shame oh
well every every time I die which is
quite often I will try to spawn on a
plane and just give me that controller
yes I'll just toss Rob the Xbox
controller once once we get on a plane
some playing keyboard a mouse obviously
we're playing on PC but it's what am i
doing I'm getting deep heat out here
Dane was it open I can't can't be going
prone out in the open
cypher only have one squad member now
Ornelas to a lot earlier when i was
getting that guy doing the guy [ __ ] and
i reviving me he couldn't oh yeah there
you get you get mad at people for no
reason Rob oh my god I just saw this
dude pulling up on us got tunnel snakes
tunnel snakes rule where the tunnel
snakes that's us and we rule rule tunnel
snakes rule we're the tunnel snakes I
was thinking man fall out it's a hell of
jaws tunnel snake so much break there
are no jets my friend there are only
arrows maybe maybe if we get a actually
there were chance bananas secret weapons
of World War 2 expansion pack yeah some
helicopters yeah I think they mentioned
that sure seems like that's something
that they might mutual kill over there
close beta is on PC only I believe so
yes I think so as well and that's all we
have
help
I got no squad mates near me at all but
that's alright I got Fast Eddie whoo
right here by my side
we're trailing a little bit here in this
conquest match but I believe I believe
we can I believe that we will win I
believe that we will win
is there a Springfield sniper rifle I
bet there is but I believe that's Justin
and that's an American sniper rifle so I
don't think we'll we'll see it anytime
soon
Springfield 1911's 1903 Springfield 1903
s that's it was manufactured I think
just like how the oh thanks man yeah I
appreciate I really appreciate that I
realize the mg 32 or 42 the support
machine gun let's take a look after this
okay sure
go to the support class see there was
only one take it look like the assault
class you could switch to the P psi P
psh that Russian submachine can look
like each which to that that was the
only like option as far as weapons go
it's pretty bare-bones here for this
pose alpha yeah I think there's there
might be someone in our area is there
someone in there I'm just like running
circles now I think okay cool I think
we're good on objective e so next
when is Opa Opa beta I believe there's
only open beta I don't know if there's
open alpha yeah they usually don't do
open alphas right I think generally
they've in the past with EA and like
battlefield 1 they've done
closed alpha closed beta and an open
data and I think again that's around
like August time so in tight it's
usually the cadence of these these sorts
of things
oh I feel so out in the open where y'all
that no way all that where they at where
they at no oh
come Coast capture sweet its burnin is
burning shaadi fire burnin on the dance
floor oh wow so I think that's an old
shot case well I'm not a fan up on all
why that came to mind but it is what it
is man man it's so in battlefield is
like this constant
ring-around-the-rosy of objectives that
usually happens it's like you capture
one you move on to the next the one
behind you gets captured and I should I
concentrate upon defending my house
however Wiggins the Alpha ei was lucky
enough give us sorry I got lucky we're
playing now they were nice enough to
give us a code for our coverage and
streaming purposes yes so let's see what
we got over here how long has the closed
alpha been out as of 1:00 a.m. this
morning 1:00 a.m. Pacific time this
morning Rob Hanlon was on top of it very
early
I am trash I am clean the door Vic Beth
[Music]
okay oh let's check out support yes you
died it's yeah and then I want to get
that sub from machine gun and heli
machine some good to that deploy over
okay support class for class click that
let's see what you can know so you can
get the Bren you do a fire mode so I've
been messing around with that all by
think I think you can change out maybe
some other loadouts here if you click
like not your pistol but like your two
gadgets so you have all right here we a
multi feel tank it's got that ammo I got
one sittin hurt clicking what's the like
the only thing you can switch is the
sofa medic yeah looks like we have okay
we have medical crate medical grade
provided a fixed health fix healing
position for squats or elucidation yeah
medical pouch heal eNOS heal eNOS that's
cute Buhl eNOS that's nice it's a new
word ah snipers I don't think so one of
the guys says that you can switch to the
mg42 I don't think so man
at least maybe you can't if you're an
ally but apparently were axis for this
mg42 is it was a
machine gun right oh yeah that's right
and which is weird that you're also I
think you're using is that the Bren
what's that the brand is a British of a
British assault this or machine gun but
this I don't know what's this gonna call
this doesn't look like a German yeah
it's definitely not German okay I think
this is like a British gun it is yeah
the Bren is a British gun Bren like the
Sten so then is what I'm thinking of
that's the one with the clip on the side
yeah that was that was also British man
I am NOT doing hot at all
cool man it's a subclass blow out we I
don't think we can switch to it what is
someone is insinuating that we can get
the mg42 but I doesn't look like it yeah
I'm sure later on yeah mg 42s
are not available it seems in this
closed alpha battlefield five tests so
let me just take a quick look at the
overview planes yep give me joy wait
which one which one
oh that middle one oh I'm sorry that's
fine Oh take it away Rob
the brand and the stand are British guns
I don't know why as access I can respond
with them but what's really tight is
that you can swap between your your Ford
firing machine guns and like your cannon
okay I see in the corner over there and
you're switching with y-yeah as a
fighter this guy
can you see Rob yeah I'm good okay we
got some plane action for everyone out
there Rob is on the control yeah I'm
sorry okay got stay hydrated man ooh
[Applause]
looks like our ticket count has evened
out close match so far but we still
still got a long ways to go
why buy me sounds like he's right on my
wing all right well that went well
where's my sub Hey so we'll come back to
uh come back to the plane
we'll get back on it I like I like the
stupid because I can at least bomb it
around oh wow great nice of you man
getting flanked I am having the worst
look today I'm sorry yeah let me try and
step it up oh man I want to spot spawn
get him boy get him
good work weirdo torpedo let me try and
help you for a second here
yeah a more consider with giving amyl
than actually shooting enemies which is
uh yeah she got heli son man hey man
keeps his promise
conquest captured car yeah if I had top
going 101 music I would have played
better
Duncan sunset it does take a while yeah
come on man you alright why are you
tripping I don't even give him any good
doing I get on the back and said fool
quit trippin I'm like an awkward moment
you think do you want it like are we
doing like a hug or handshake or like
food stop playing
you know you might alright that's what's
your favorite class I like the metaclass
but that uh
Gewehr yeah is is dope like that's good
thing it's good guy Oh semi
tag though
Sasaki there is no customization in this
closed alpha but there will be in the
final game yes damn this will be tossing
pools of probably quarterbacking
in high school so now that you played a
little bit how do you feel about it in
comparison to outfield one hmm I do
notice the the movement is a little bit
more it feels a little bit more tighter
I would say a little less floaties and
not that I really ever had too much of
an issue with the movement adopting one
but I do feel like this one's a little
bit it's yeah it's hard to describe yeah
it honestly is but it does feel good it
does feel good
feels good green like that it doesn't
the movement of the foot soldiers
doesn't feel changing yeah like the
again like if I point at anything it's
like the clambering and and the actions
you in interactions you have with like
your environment feel tighter and more
like intentionally ever ever it like yes
like you'd kind of have the sense of
like oh I could probably jump here and
clamber successfully and it and it looks
and feels legit so it's it's the one to
one of like movement is is tighter at
the lichen valve over five here yeah I
have no I have no qualms about the
movement and everything seems like it's
working out quite well I'd still haven't
really gotten into any vehicles so I
can't comment on that the tank felt a
little little Nikki you know
oh there we go finally yes look Chris I
haven't I can't believe you've done this
our Sturm give yours in this man what am
i doing the prompt would show up and
then would go away and then would show
up again went away maybe I'm just the
dumb ass but you know that was a little
tank right there
Oh Jacob Decker is now online this is a
quite the match man we're down about 50
tickets and I I ain't doing my salon no
favors me let's see if I can pick it up
again this is battlefield 5 alpha
gameplay closed alpha so you know we're
trying to do our best
I'm out open I'm about to get shot it's
all good though
alright we're doing that objective
ring-around-the-rosie again we'll see if
we can find better success spotting
enemies is and has been definitely
turned down as far as how easy it is in
the previous games or the previous game
like it takes longer to spot I believe
you can't like earlier where there's
comparison like like the previous games
in the series you could just like being
a plane it's just mash spot and like see
everyone the map it's not like that like
it's more selective which I think it's
fine and I almost want to say also like
the spotting doesn't last as long oh
yeah I want to say like like the icon
will disappear fairly quickly on an
enemy
okay where's my squads game ciphers over
there all right I want to feel like I'm
abandoning them though you know I want
to get objectives but I don't want to
bend in my like good friends
weirdo torpedo and game cipher cool we
got that deep yeah that's the one thing
oh it's too late yes we gonna kill
assist there oh sweet I'll take it game
cipher oh no sorry man Lawrence Harding
has a has a good question what's he
asking he asks
if you could afford battlefield 5 or
black ops for which one would you choose
I haven't I would say about personally
battlefield always I'm more of about
battlefield ballplayer but I am
genuinely interested in what Call of
Duty's doing with black ops yeah for
because it seems like they're going like
kind of all in on that hero shooter
business and wondering if they can pull
it off and wonder what they're gonna do
with their battle royale type type thing
going on I'm dead
oh [ __ ] okay I just saw what's up in
jae-in I can't say his name in Jenko go
to deployment oh okay yeah after you
yeah past gotta wait to pass out
okay over here yeah what I'm saying -
there's an icon next so click click that
okay oh yeah okay he was right because
apologies machine gunner Wow Wow
there you go mg42 Janko thank you for
that yeah you're absolutely right yes my
bad
thank you for that tip we really
appreciate it we'll have to check out
other subclasses then oh look at that
beauty Becky look at this machine gun
alright let's see we can do anything
with it I wonder what the recoil is like
let's find out like on a hip fire Big
Jim bronies sing yes you got a perch up
yeah use that bipod yeah I wonder if
there is if I just do 80s while I'm on
like a barrier yeah generally I will
auto set up like that
uncover because hip firing is not the
business but mg42
because that is not what it is
specifically used for or FICO prone or
something oh oh yeah yeah so prone for
sure oh look at that I'm on my bad
you're back man it's hard to tell what I
can deploy on I'm sorry yes this is
interesting that I do want to check out
if there's other options for other yeah
for sure any other classes but for now
let's try and see what we can do with
them with the mg42
mm-hmm okay where you have to defend
this town we have some WOD calls
available in this bill this is the big
jabroni are you referring to like those
captain abilities because I think it to
be a captain order to do that
but there are like basic squad calls
where you can just point an objective
and be like hey go here or I need help
odd why no I'm not doing our squad any
favors oh oh oh click that top one
what's that
what is this artillery artillery I don't
know it looks look beefy this thing is
beefy lordy Lord what do we have here
I answers a gigantic tank this is a unit
look at the weight on this lad oh oh I'm
taking down some telephone poles my
power telephone poles to take it down
some power lines I mean or tell em both
same same thing all right we're gonna
try and see what we could do yeah go to
E and alum have it so you got a weirdo
torpedo oh oh oh yes no no you got some
resume on it too much oh there's a guy
that's my boy no no dude to the left oh
sure new tack oh yeah it's a little
janky but oh it has a very short range
dead ahead
dead ahead
some guys cross the street oh damn I
need my glasses psych I'm just not doing
quite well over here Oh just crush it
Oh Oh run him over ah down oh no a gun
assists mom I got a couple my squad
mates here with me wait yes comes out
October what was it again 1919 okay we
good we have teammates get an objective
so I'm gonna move on to see do you want
to rock it yeah
what's the Churchill crocodile sounds
like a dance move you don't know about
the Churchill crocodile sounds
take it down all these all these
buildings come up huh squads like what
the hell is you doing I'm doing work
that's what oh lordy lord I can't turn
around to flamethrower tank is the
crocodile prepared you gotta hold it
damage looking good looking good looking
good looking good
oh yes look at that repair back up to 72
be good be good
oh I need to revive the home provide the
home you do need forget that guy you're
a chick baby oh my god he's his head is
in the dirt you know I look at this I'm
just like you didn't really get shot
lioness can't like no one took your tank
Oh yet so you got some smoke there I can
actually hit it on the controller to see
if it's a horse
what's that I don't know - do that I
don't know I didn't take much damage I
think I did that so you got smoke Oh
smoke hope we never do blazing up over
here about all you want y'all want to
get in you all want to get in get in
baby let's get this it's got the subject
of a oh I see a guy but my turret does
not swing around that direction so yeah
I've seen the v1 rocket yeah that's fine
ooh Oh oh that's a guy out there launch
it that's it oh this is got to be short
range oh we're already losing the
objective Caesar you just took that oh
it's a struggle
whoa that was a view one for sure god oh
[ __ ]
smoke
Oh am i doing
No
I'm so dumb I'm gonna kill you just I
think you just my lady that whole
building I got a kill by those artillery
exist in the game I believe it does but
I don't think we see it here plane plane
plane uh middle one middle yeah yeah
yeah and then deploy deploy get that
give me get it Rob I'm so excited for
you
it's so hard to dogfight a Spitfire in
his in a stupid oh he's out turn me we
got the we got the upper hand on the
ticket count all right I'm gonna say
screw this guy
oh don't crash at all please don't crash
hoodies on crash don't crash I'm sorry
Rob
I'm sorry I'm sorry I suck at flying I'm
normally pretty good that was really
embarrassing
alright last me stream today man more
archetypes coming soon so I guess Oh try
another subclass oh yeah I think maybe
support yes okay just that one
yeah supports the only one that's got a
different archetype is they call it so
Oh let's deploy we must protect this
house deploying how do you learn how the
whole stuff God the chats delayed I
can't like see it is it I'm just waiting
for the inevitable like I know that was
a stall I know I stalled I messed up I
didn't judge it was what the Chris Evans
Jones my god I only I mentioned Chris
Evans once they're all in it he is not
the he's not the best Avenger I would
say
who's your favorite Avenger Black
Panther I would say it's my favorite
event Avenger but besides he asked
besides him I would say Tony start
school but he's my favorite big fan that
suit yeah I mean Iron Man suit this is
cool it's a crime they do this the
zookas have the iconic Jericho dive now
we're now we cooking with gas come on I
dare y'all to roll up on me I just want
to tear some fools up man he's not in my
squad so I can't revive him so if y'all
should that's one thing we should try
doing is building stuff maybe you can do
it oh yeah so you do I know you duty to
pull your hammer but I would wait and
kill these dudes first oh hell yeah come
on come on boy come on
come on boys it's more accurate when
you're laying down right yup you feel it
definitely a big-time dudes are a little
far but I should probably try and get
that objective and that gun sounds good
that's fine
you can hear the clanging of the barrel
like he's tied I got too aggressive man
the match is so close 22 to 22 ticket
count Kevin I know I was dogfighting in
a bomber I didn't have a gunner on me
you guys leave me alone this isn't
looking good man this isn't looking good
the flags are in their favor for now see
back come on
sup boy Alice I got one kill with mg
so you can customize soldiers not in
this build later on
looking good now you're done dude you've
done Sun it down son dang certain I'm
still a close match but I really didn't
pull my weight in that one
let's just go to 10 okay let's my step
out
no no can swap in you wanna do you mind
if I oh yeah of course okay all right I
did what I could
you did good it's my very first time
playing battlefield 5 at least I got I
got a few mg42 kills towards the end
right there left that felt really good
when you at least got to deploy it
it's very steady the bullets feel like
they're laying down some damage high
rate of fire oh we're the squad leader
now you are the squad leader so maybe we
can do that that cool cool move where
you can like what do like well like
there so that v1 rocket and stuff okay
some of those those capabilities
relegated to oh oh oh Riley Wow Rob's
got his hands on a plane again and see
if you can do some damage damn it I want
a goner Lee alone
oh yeah oh you want to go less go get
them get them Rob vehicle hit vehicle
hit stupa we got some Snuka fans out
there
i intere no no
if you repair do you lose any
capabilities and I can still fly in an
interesting in battlefield one you were
unable to turn oh really yeah so it was
tough to repair it but it looks like
they changed that so what are you
getting a lot of turned no my like [ __ ]
my engines cut out no all right is that
what does that ring there that's how I
refill ammo okay Ric I I see you guys
it's very realistic
Oh dropping bombs your little little a
time drop there or what I would say
maybe maybe a little late but also a
little yeah oh you got shot out of the
sky man rats
oh it's getting late in the day it is
it's almost 10 o'clock in the morning
over here it's getting late we're gonna
have to all right at home after this
hell no oh looks like there's some what
am i unlocking stuff I didn't see those
progression things earlier
maybe I'm just blah am i unlocking
weapons because of leveling up
I would I would just expect to see them
just like straight up like no Kabul yeah
or like a lock in front of in saying
yeah like yeah great our whatever but
that's weird
I feel like I didn't see the mp40 until
now oh yeah might be tripping it seems
cool alright you know who needs me your
squad that's right yes get it let's help
out our boys game safer like the guy in
the chat Devils marksman says Matt you
[ __ ]
okay got robbed back on the controls
here at warming up yeah is it takes time
to get a little used to the controls I
was just getting back into the flow of
things it's been a while since I played
battlefield one yeah that's my excuse
spider
it's a very fair oh wait oh look at that
was it well I just saw it what happened
oh here oh that's your [ __ ] your squad
leader capabilities so I need to just be
better as a squad leader so and it'll
unlock some money I think I got it oh
god damn it god I'm so sorry gonna be in
a good squad leader I lost one stabbed
your friends that man get that morphine
and they blowed alright that's it I've
had it with this mess we got no food
we got no jobs Birds heads are falling
off our pets pets are falling off I want
to go someplace where we know somebody
I'm tired
peace
you just want to see that girl yeah yeah
so yeah so I it came to mind because
this map reminds me of a speech I tell
these guys to do we got okay let's go to
direct them towards an objective I think
that's very helpful even though that's
like a little thing as when I'm part of
a squad and the squad leader says hey
let's all converge on objective see like
for example makes me feel like okay
we're all working towards there I can
rely on them being there it's really
helpful for capping objected so even if
even if it's just like a little thing
like that
yeah for sure I really like that [ __ ]
part of the reason why I like
battlefield 2 so much is because of the
squad the new squad mechanics I think
battlefield 2 was the first Battlefield
game to introduce squad mechanics like
that I think it added a lot so that game
especially in 2005 well we didn't see
much of that in video games
get on follow me on Twitter and Robert
handler II on a more followers
Oh Riley that how'd that need to I don't
know I think it was smoking weed or
something look legit oh yeah that's a
smoke nade that's your smoke I know I
knew that damn it I did the same thing
to smoke hurting me can't breathe oh
this looks like the trailer stairway
Here I am looking at the architecture
like I'm trying to buy the place if this
is out in San Francisco I think this
house would be about 2.5 million minimum
it's tough out here in the bay I take
the house no walls no windows no problem
it's all good to me yeah in this
condition it would still be 2.5 trust me
we we're not far off
let me spawn my team my team needs me
I'll watch a lot of HGTV I know what I'm
talking about
yeah property Bros Jonathan Scott drew
Scott good boys oh my god I know I
thought here's a med pack I know you're
dying but uh here's a med pack Michael I
think I'm losing oh that would have been
sick excuse me for yelling it happens
it's video games man we're sure anything
oh yes hey hey you okay you're right
it's so awkward
that's do you know it yeah that revive
animation is so funny to me because
basically what your teammate is saying
is like what are you what the hell are
you laying down for it can get us oh
yeah like you did not get shot boy
uh-huh
tripping you call that a head shot get
your ass all right
let's let's go do uh let's take b-boys
name design how did you turn on toggle
oh sorry yeah I did I did a 80s toggle
play that's how you preferred
I also turned down the sensitivity in
case you were wondering
[Music]
soldier weapon zoom polled yeah I'm used
to toggle for most things interesting
yeah I inverted yes you are
no yes as in yes as long as I'm not I
don't know why you would ever invert
your mouse I guess I don't know there's
no there's no way a mouse but controller
I guess you can't on a controller it's
fine if that's your thing but I mouse
I'm trying
[Laughter]
try to bug the booth on that one
how would you go Jude here I'm gonna
stir then get him get him plain like a
note let's not be rash aughts tight play
corners like it's like it's CS smoke
grenade I think they actually blew up
all right an aide r.i.p dog I guess
that's the grenade indicators affecting
an actual icon the old fella
there's no leaning in this is there yeah
there is others yeah like you can't man
oh it's a surround objective Genesis
objects no right trippin yeah I see oh
you get your ass up there we go get some
bad juice Oh promoted as a medic corners
like the cellos get this guy pump them
up stab them right in the rifle you know
what I'm saying is your rifle good boy
oh come on hip firing on the like a bear
43 what is just kidding you're fine you
revived your friends got you will great
ask can you play conquests in this bill
boy we're playing it we playing it yeah
conquests and grant operations is in the
battlefield 5 closed alpha and we've
been playing conquest for Moses yeah
because I think it's a little bit easier
to get into a match we had a little bit
of trouble trying to get into a grand
Operations match I don't know if that
was just the server's at that time so
someone we haven't really seen much of
as far as most the e3 coverage all that
you through coverage was focused on
grand operations defense max Oh classic
conquests oh cool here we go
whoa you don't want to build in front of
that fool
take them out away
you mean it jumped out jump down that's
him anyway so saying like we can build
some transparent icons here indicating
that we can build something see I mean I
guess these are already put up oh so
we're like okay right here oh okay here
we go we're showing off some building
we're about through two and a half hours
of the stream and we're finally showing
some building combat engineer honours
you constructed a fortification well
congratulations well well look at meter
now an engineer on being a team player
yeah some some of my homies went school
for six years to learn how to be
engineers look at you you did it in two
and a half hours you know it was just
easy so you could blow this up right I
suppose another weird noise yeah
come on I'll be cool but it wasn't but
it wasn't it's all right
at least we you got a lot get a lot of
objective points it's important
yeah it's play objectives our teams
deployed overview sure I'll fly Oh Rob
is back on the planes right now let's
see a fly boy over here
Kjetil dang it
nice oh snap that's 40 damage on them
it's nothing to scoff at
oh how my grandfather get it
Wow she would switch the keyboard supply
you're going down bro I love that quick
cut out yeah Milo Milo
alright let's get back to this try this
you know what I need to help out my team
Wow early stream missed the start much
doe he very well it was it was it was
poppin man if you wanna if you want to
watch it back I'll boot do a Ken comment
yeah let's just say there was a there
was a very good moment within a within a
three hour stream I think it'll be hard
to find that but Rob got your back put a
comment in the YouTube replay cuz it was
it's quite the moment I would say
highlight of my day
follow me back up tank there I built
here okay yeah a lot of these buildings
go down fairly easily to tanks tank
shells bombs and stuff so you can put
them back together with a few of
sandbags oh yeah I got all the way
that's what happened all right good job
team do this yet throw up a couple
sandbags
all right I'm like halfway there I can
do the flamethrower tank but I can't
want you to be rocket yeah that beat
they'll be interesting
so we're have you seen those explosions
or gigantic yep not soon let's go to see
check this see
objective-c Caesar take turn that C blue
cuz o bleeding out your squad don't even
have your back man not that great of a
leader in this game man
what no gotta prove yourself and love em
no just watching you're watching your
friends get mowed down man they hate me
huh yeah but there's a tank here there
it is she's looking what killed yourself
did I no no I'm just kidding you I don't
know what happened to you man hey come
on come on Seifer this this will through
a medical pack at you from from afar
he's like oh man you look he had it [ __ ]
out you look busted you don't even need
to flip anything out to revive your
squad man he was a medic what a jackass
he said you look like you need a med
pack it's all right game ciphers been a
good teammate most of the time his body
is fire
bad guy man buggin out make it snow
angels
alright what should we do here let's go
to see stick god watch planks No
jump through those windows use that
mobility
close that door oh the fireplace nice
and toasty you're just you're just
chilling chilling it upstairs while your
your friends are on the ground back out
back into it got to take cover
get into the town we ain't doing too hot
on objectives here are we
I don't think so y'all are down 100
tickets the other teams has the has a
flag advantage for most of the match
standing on the table
[Laughter]
death dealer he's not dealing much death
stand on that table but we believe in
him is our teammate the Chris Evans chat
is still going on when you bleed out
Chris Evans make sure you were reborn
again thanks thanks Chris sorry man
we've been at it for quite some time so
if you all still got some questions let
us know again we're playing the
battlefield 5 closed alpha so we got
access we've been at it Rob's been at it
it's about 5 o'clock in the morning
[Music]
actually I think he slept here slept in
the stream room you wore that shirt
yesterday they did your hair isn't
exactly the same places yesterday we're
the same exact glasses yesterday that's
true I did sleep got you man caught up
oh good call my man let's take F well
last if I'm squad member died here it's
very in your face like okay I get it I
get it
I'm trying to aim oh [ __ ] five your boy
I do in my life dude it's been a long
day
what do you see you can see your squad
mate down pull out the panzerschreck oh
look we're doing great yeah I'm doing
okay
oh man it's alright it's our F it's
alright well there's you know these are
these are big games you know it's 32
versus 32
you can't win them all alright that's it
unless you rob Hanlon who's about to
make a comeback
whoa goodbye to third person labels
helmets hanging from the back of the
tank some details over there that's all
in the comrades
looks like we haven't got any
we got a heads head tank battle match
coming up over here
I think it's at Harvard oh no that's
time is that a friendly it is Oh looks
like we don't have a 1v1
tank battle rate but we will find one oh
yeah you want to go you want to go
what's that
you wanna throw shells dude oh I see you
okay I see you shaking that ass excuse
me
come on Meza that's a dude apples
popping up with his panzerschreck
streck's pulling up on you okay where
Shrek at for the pants of Shrek and as
our base I'm a believer
I got that damn squadmates getting mad
at you for doing what I don't know being
hot it is a little stuffy in this room I
see you have this one-on-one rivalry
oh there's two tracks they're not doing
much yeah they are doing some damage
doing about 20 damage per shot that's
gonna do it today goddamn squad gunner
hey your yeah your squad wasn't helping
out much but you know you did tell them
to go take objective F while you were
chilling in the tank but you know we're
just trying to show off some different
features in battlefield 5 so you know oh
you were close to the objective there's
nothing nothing to do but get back to it
and do it well that's alright oh man
we've been at it since 7 o'clock so
start to a little fatigue yeah starting
to get a little little lazy with our
with our tactics but you know what we
can bring it back there's time oh yes
see he's already he's already on point
again oh right right there see
jiya it's coming back it's coming back
to us sometimes you know Wow let me get
shot up switch a little bit that might
look Pablo
no one's there to help all planes want
to fly again
just let Rob fly so sue me hashtag let
Rob fly alright it's uh drop some bombs
man
get it what have you considered I want
if you can tuck in tuck in the wheels
he'll know all right then on this plane
okay Stukas didn't have wheels so good
so that the the infamous dive-bombing
it's called like the Jericho scream
wherever it's gotten it's got propellers
on its landing gear mm-hmm that would
make me know is yeah I just get a
freaking kill it's on you man
yep we have 91 tickets left we're
definitely not going to win this match
but we can do some something spectacular
with the time we have left get it oh you
don't have any bombs to drop
you got a hammer you're absolutely right
oh let's get some ammo let's fly through
some rings over here where's that it's
pilot wings Halloweens where is it I
would see a floating ring in the sky
there's one over here
does it change as the match goes on it's
like there's one behind and Ike on each
side that was nice oh you got a got a
squad mate behind you or in your cockpit
you get it those bombs boy whoa it's a
lot of a lot of motion blur yeah
aberration it honestly looks like a
little buggy Oh
oh my god we finally got Bob's no stop
no all right I'm fine I believe in you
man I believe in you Rob this whole
thing
I hear here everyone get into work
repairing that plane that's right I can
still fly okay 45 I'll take it
right now it's chance man you got two
bombs to drop Oh looks like we have a
lot of taken over a lot of junkies you
try and drop a bomb on top of it I'm a
little cocky you did get that uh
panzerschreck kill
I'll pick up some more bombs up
can you land the plane and I could try
does have wheels should i but I don't
know if there's any leg I don't think
there's enough space anywhere in this
map yeah I don't test that for another
day I don't know why you would want to
do that because planes are meant to fly
here we're making a little progress here
yeah seems like we got almost all the
objectives
I wonder if has to do with me not being
on the ground Oh drop that I think it
was a good it was a good drop but I
don't know if any visitor yeah have this
thousand kilogram bomb in his office
oh yeah damn that's a big one too oh who
are you oh we're Oh pull up pull up
Oh skimmed it damn nice flying Rob
thanks - I'm stalling in Russian for
food no time for Stalin I said that
about two hours ago I can say it again
alright guys I got this big bomb here
I'll assume it I see a guy here drop it
on the flo Oh enemy hit does that mean
you got a killer or not no damn [ __ ]
I always forget to drop it grab behind
me
drop it low like this money on flow
[Music]
robbed her you get the rocket do you
have access to the video someone by the
name what I checked know someone by the
name of GameSpot and the channel I don't
buy this Rob hurry get the rocket did I
screw that I was so bad you got like 10
seconds not 10 seconds probably like I'm
1-800 free but you hear the music pump
it up
deploy a point
no that's under contention poi deploy
deploy do you have access to you got to
make a call hello can i order a
pepperoni pizza wings and a flame tank
damn well it's one of the things we fail
to show off today
Wow like must be killing bleeding out
with your squad comes over you back in
the fight defeats wasn't able to get the
rocket sorry guys but that's gonna do it
literally not playing that well so I
think we need to break we'll be
streaming this probably tomorrow I don't
know yeah we have this is going on till
what is it July 2nd I believe for
everyone anyone who has access to the
closed beta we yeah we're probably going
to do a lot more videos on this now that
we have access to the game we've been
playing it but yeah stick around we have
a lot more streams coming on today any
lost last thoughts you want to give the
audience out there about battlefield 5
close alpha it's pretty cool pretty cool
so far
yep I shot a plane out of the sky with
the panzer fast that was a highlight
yep go back and watch that that was fun
the guns feel good the ruling is
freshing for some reason I don't know
what maybe just not and I know I'm on
set but yeah the movie min is great yeah
it's real great it's tight
it's good sign for something that's you
know again close alpha so we'll see we
saw soft some few bugs there's a little
some janky stuff but you know again to
close alpha so hopefully we can see some
improvements as yam goes on but yeah
that is battlefield 5 the closed alpha
we got to play conquest and a little bit
of grant operations and we've been at it
for about 3 hours now so I think we need
to get to we need to get some work out
here at GameSpot so yeah with that we're
gonna close this out now stick around
because we got GameSpot daily at 11
o'clock and I think we're gonna be
streaming something else afterwards at
11:30 definitely all kinds of shows
going on for you on gamespot comm twitch
youtube and our site so yeah thank you
for hanging out watching us play find
some success not so much success but you
know we had fun and we hope you had fun
definitely and we'll see you again soon
goodbye everybody